ah there we go so what iris let me yell
stop dropping out when the [ __ ] I'm
one of you girlfriend says time is
marketing your pen we want the building
so once again yeah very hitting here I'm
like jeez oh my god
t4 Terry what's left me [ __ ]
thanks for playing with us zombies we
appreciate you please we're going right
into the middle of a great triangle
ye - five six nah see a smattering of
zombies with us but well no the hope is
that we get military gear here so yes we
should we try to land on one roof land
right there
good we're going next to the three
titties oh I'm kind of are behind you
guys so oh there's a zombie right behind
you mark oh [ __ ] oh right makeup right
between you and me Oh they landed on the
roof of like the school building over
here yeah so they're there they're up on
that roof of that great school building
that we just flew over it's funny that
the I'm right next to Mars don't get
creepy hello in this modal okay we got
ya one does a backpack for you latex
I'll take the backpack yeah you take
that grab everything and I'm fine oh
come on who's got a gun who's got a gun
thank you thank you thank you I have a
gun sorry Oh a kid there was no wave got
a bacon jam engine yeah gonna be a dick
about it way damn look nada
it wasn't going to happen but I'm not
sure there's a level two backpack on me
if anyone needs a bag I in the bag Freyr
here there's scars and there's am fours
on me I'm gonna come towards Jackson
coming away I'm gonna wait don't go
that's why we're here alright I'll stay
with you it will study gonna I kind of
moved away leave you guys
I need that there's an auto shotgun on
me as all stay at the minimum staying
groups of two guys just watch each
other's backs well one person's eluding
the other person should just be like not
okay not in the menus it's weird because
sniper rifles are the thing you should
be using for main game but for this it's
all a RS yeah because you need as many
bullets as possible it's the big yeah
it's like but oh I don't have a lot of
heals people have a lot of real yeah I
got none the first aid kits I've got a
three all marked another and four worth
or if you'd rather have less than oh no
I found another one later so I got that
so we need to get to a vehicle so we
should get moving like left towards the
road and see if we can find a jeep or
something other than performance on the
island too so we don't figure that for
understand it and on the brakes we
should be good
oh well we could run it we're a little
behind the times and we don't need to
start running right now or find a
vehicle yeah there's no vehicle here
then oh here's a motorcycle it's a two
seater two people could take that and
try to find out the three theatres
actually that's true three people can
pick out four to find other vehicle and
pick one of those up we got a plane
coming our way I don't know nobody US
but yeah
oh my god it's off Jesus that drop
should land near us alright oh we're
right next to the circle so literally
YouTube can just run up a foot to get to
the circle ball you wanna go on a cruise
for a car does everyone have sight I
have no accent 2x I'm going on those I
have no scope okay
I haven't read done you can get 360
noscopes wait here's a motorcycle yeah
don't get that's and then we'll have two
sets sure all right we got vehicles in
case we need it
okay come to me I have scopes on the way
I've got I don't have any magnification
or am
wait wait wait chill Jesus whoa what
does looks like you just rode fast
jacket like full-blast picking a red dot
on me are we are we
piecing out oh wait this let me check
did anyone check these buildings here
mark did you know a good attachments cuz
the same for is decked out yeah I did
yeah you take that I got more
attachments though you sure one yeah
okay I feel kind of better good answer
I'll go I'll go with uh well our Jack
don't forget to press X if you need more
speed as well what does that yep put
your gun away which makes you run faster
that's right
it's basically taking out a knife and
see it I'm taking the five five six and
again in the road while you guys search
it I've cleared my building we're so
[ __ ] triad right now well we're not
going to die like [ __ ] we're not
zombies in the first two minutes so that
I can't believe if we've got to kill
awakened at the very beginning of the
game because that was kind of a sweet
vengeance if you guys find an extra
extended mag or a quick draw for a
assault rifle like an easel for the s12
but now I've got what for my main so
it's okay if you don't I think I've got
quick draws on both my mains but I don't
have any extra stuff okay I'm ready
Pete's out whenever in it whenever it's
a blue the blue is uh not actually that
close neveress how people go give me
give me just a little bit longer I'm
just finding more ammo and I know that
ammo is king here so yeah the ammo
situation I feel like I don't have
enough and I have like 500 rounds of
ammo between all my guns yeah all right
well should we get out of here all right
I'm with alright I'll go with you bubble
oh oh I'm with okay city yeah we know I
don't want her here and let me get the
other wah
cuz I can show me more okay yeah 403
just don't shoot me because you can
shoot me alright will not shoot you
maybe please don't look it's kind of my
best it's going to be a scooter of a
[ __ ] round so oh oh yeah we've only
killed one zombie all this time do you
guys want to play the bridge to get kind
of a choke point or should we move in oh
god no that night we could mold out a
bedroom I will also keep an eye out for
gasoline so we can fill this thing up if
we need a quick bit away I would play
the bridge spot Oh what color are we
going to not end there
[Laughter]
better watch INXS we are rich in the
hell out things are not the way to know
I was doing a great job driving I got no
problem with driving like an on insane
person so oh we're good I know it'd be
crazy it's what I do
yeah across this cornfield is terrifying
though yeah god yeah oh just please not
please don't understand but we're gonna
kiss I get nervous during normal Pub G
matches but like 10 trips I know my
butthole okay okay right that doesn't
sound like something those okay the side
of a building what is with the fire
let's get out and oh okay right so uh
okay I'm not open here oh the doors are
beating down there Sam Sam oh they're
zombies of this building Jack I saw
movement in here okay all right zombie
are you fighting like you're at fight
wait I totally couldn't open doors they
can break them they can break them if
doors are broken off the hinges it means
there's zombies okay I'm checking people
doing on med kits and boosters we're
good I don't know first aid kit don't
spend too much time in that house
because there's not a balcony to jump
off of which is terrifying
I had zero first aid Bob you know I
don't need any are we trying Harding or
not right now we are tryharding we're
try Harding
Oh captain my cap I'm tryharding but I
know the game Bob this is gonna sound
stupid but I don't have a pistol yet
zombie zombie coming in now stopped
coming to the house which house no
you're in our way okay okay don't forget
to follow when you're getting close I'm
gonna shout cut out this don't you have
a little drop is landing on us
I've got no no chuckles I'm full all the
way yeah oh we got zero bandages zero
perfect
oh wait coming to me keep losing weight
keep looting there's a the drop is
coming at 300 right now
should we hey buddy
wait for it to in here yeah I object
Wade come to me okay on my way there
[ __ ] on the floor that you can use my
eyes have never been so open in my
goddamn life I walk bro are you woke
right now are you feel gettable oh I'm
not rose
yeah the drop is like in this be who
they keep it tight boy I don't see Ana
tombos running for it which is pizza a
new sight zombies want that awm that's
going to happen I would have hang back
here with Bob while you to push forward
yeah I'm going to keep a little bit of a
overwatch on you guys we also have we
also put [ __ ] right next to a so
that's a loot if we needed here we lost
them all I'm toast um I'm good okay
there's another plane coming into my
shop right honest to what do you have an
eight times yes I do you know PSLV I I
gave away one to Wade yeah oh I know
okay God Sarah leave but he definitely
did it who shot oh those the smoke all
movement there's movement run to the
field from the earth what Nautica oh
there's an m249 here I see it I see it I
see it that's coming for you Jack you
are in trouble okay okay wait keep
watching me keep watching me okay sick
lag I can't take what the [ __ ] off my
god we got behind us - oh [ __ ] they're
all around us make a way back to Bob
Boone waves come back this when I come
back to slice wait are you still
watching me am I good you're still good
I thought I saw crawling in the grass to
the south-southeast but I think oh just
a graphical glitch okay I got an m249 so
we're good nice that's a good fine
so you have a hundred shots before it
hits another drop one nine five
Oh behind us behind the fence behind it
yeah I have three hosts 300m Oh for this
thing so we're good
oh man they're swarming backdrop there
are so many 300 right now oh they're old
light them up light em up
all I have our iron plate oh my god
better oh boy I don't fly them up I
don't like it right behind me behind you
on the car wash it oh [ __ ] guys fight
back to the motorcycles it's time to go
yeah we got to go humming hello there
all of us fight back to the motorcycle
to me to me to me
whoo on me on me on me up down we are
down right now thing does not reload
quickly we've got a shotgun we getting
pizza remotely oh boy well last damn
time
mark out this come with me bastards come
at me come on me the last one alive
again you want some of this oh I can't
hit [ __ ] apparently run Turner run turn
to run Oh turn to run well there's
somebody down I didn't kill a single one
you're a [ __ ] beast they're in a red
zone though but I got you know and all
that oh well I got Grenada come at me
the exact same as last time 23 Rd
[Music]